the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good evening people we continue our
discussion of neo realism by looking
closely tonight at one classic instance
of the neo-realist movement but the
single most famous film from that from
that school Bicycle Thieves before we
before I turn to talking a bit about
aspects of Bicycle Thieves itself which
I hope will frame your viewing in a way
that will help you get a lot out and get
a lot out of the first viewing of the
film I want to say a few words about
vittorio de sica himself i mentioned
this afternoon that the neo-realist
movement although it was immensely
influential and continues to be
influential in fact on realist
filmmakers and on documentarians and it
was especially in its in its earliest
phases hailed globally as a very
remarkable movement it incited criticism
almost from the beginning inside Italy
and I suggested this afternoon that some
complaints against the movie essentially
came from conservative forces in the
society that felt that the portrait of
decay and breakdown and dislocation that
was at the center of neo-realist films
they after all they were about the
contemporary world and about the the the
the broken universe that we had the
broken planet that were at least the
broken Europe that we encountered after
the war there were many conservatives
who fell in in Italy who felt that it
promulgated a bad image for the society
that it made investment more difficult
than it that it was a kind of downer and
this criticism was very powerful but
what really undermined the movement in
terms of getting financing why the
reason that the movement sort of ended
after about the time Umberto D the last
of the truly neo-realist films that De
Sica made was produced in 1952 the its
life was you know very very brief that
many people would say that was the end
of neo-realism although there are some
films that come after that that have
neo-realist dimensions and elements in
them including some by Fellini
still the idea that the movement had a
very short life despite its immense
influences it is an accurate one but
what I had left out this afternoon is an
important qualification or addition
which is that the films also incited
criticism from the left you would think
that that's when you see Bicycle Thieves
you'll see why that might be a
surprising fact because the sympathies
of the film are so totally on the side
of the of the underprivileged and the
underclasses of the culture that it's
it's difficult from our contemporary
vantage point to see what would have
offended leftist but there were there
was a very vigorous and theoretically
sophisticated communist movement in
Italy in this period as there continues
to be today in some degree and and many
people on the left especially communists
but other but socialists as well also
complained about neo-realist films and
in particular about the Seekers films
because they come because their
complaint was not that the difficulties
of the world were exposed they were
perfectly happy with that but they were
angry that there wasn't a program for
renovation what they were really angry
about was that there wasn't a Marxist or
a socialist program built into the films
and it's always struck me as a very
revealing an interesting fact about the
movement that it couldn't satisfy either
left or right even though these films
are among the most powerful and
compassionate films about the lives of
ordinary not just ordinary people would
have people without power of people
without control over their lives that
have ever been made so it's it's it's a
curious fact and it bothered de sica all
his life that that he he seemed unable
to please either side in that political
argument and
and at one point in in an interview he
said something that I if I can find my
notes I'd like to quote to you he said
in response to the to a question that
asked him why do you think the
Socialists and the Communists were some
or at least some socialists and
remembers a batini was a socialist so he
collaborated deeply with and loved to
seek and collaborated with him on his
most important film so I don't mean that
all socialists thought ill of
neo-realism they did not but some did
and certainly people on the far left
definitely didn't and here was the
Seekers response to why he said he
expressed disappointment about this but
his response really in a way as a
critique of of the programmatic demands
that these that these people were making
on his films he said my films are a
struggle against the absence of human
solidarity and you should think about
this quotation as you're watching
tonight's film because there as you'll
see in the film the official
institutions of the society seem to have
broken down or at least to have been to
have become not effective they're there
they're there their overburden means
there it was somewhat indifferent it's
mostly that they're overburdened that
the problems of the society are too
great for the institutional structures
that are in place to handle it the
problems but in any case you as you're
watching the film I think you'll notice
not only clearly this breakdown of
institutions of very my --tx pecked to
be helpful to Ricci in his quest but
what we will also discover is that there
are other forms of solidarity that
emerge in the film one of them is the
Solidarity of husband and wife
another is the Solidarity very much
tested in the film it's the great
central theme of the film the Solidarity
of father and son and then there is also
the Solidarity of what we might call
neighbors or neighborhoods and you'll
see how that element works toward the
end of the film and it's remarkable and
surprising conclusion now here's the
quotation my films are a struggle
against the absence of human solidarity
against the indifference of society
towards suffering they are a word in
favor of the poor and the unhappy and
one reason I like the statement is
so in a certain sense unsystematic it
show its it may seem to me to be the
words of an artist not a political
pamphleteer and they partly explain the
richness the resident resonance what
I've been calling the multiplicity of
Bicycle Thieves
there's a moment in Bicycle Thieves
about which Andre Posner has written
very beautifully the same critic that
smokes that that was a champion of
French poetic realism and of Jean Renoir
of course becomes one of the great
champions of Italian Neorealism
he can see that that that the Italian
form of realism is an extension and
elaboration and in some ways a deepening
of the implications of poetic realism
and he and he he's written brilliantly
about the neo-realist and especially
about about De Sica
and there's one place in the film that
he particularly focuses on in one of his
essays it's a it's a monk I have to give
away a small part of the plot in order
to explain this but it really won't
trouble you because the the plot engine
gets going so early in the film that
it's hardly a surprise in fact you
really know what's going to happen
almost from the opening dialogue in the
film where people are arguing about who
has bicycles and who does not the the
film is organized in a very elegant
relatively simple way it covers
essentially three days of time the first
day is the day that in which Ricci gets
the the Commission for the job and then
go then goes with his wife to get his
bicycle out of hock and you'll see that
they have to go through certain kinds of
tricks to find the money for for to do
this and then once he has this bicycle
he goes to work and on his first day of
work guess what happens someone guess
who hasn't seen the film what do you
think might get stolen okay right
his bicycle is stolen on the first day
of work okay now the fact is you're
really not surprised when it happens
because almost from that first scene
you're aware that bicycles are this
incredibly precious object in the world
and yet also
incredibly common and that's part of why
it's such a resonant symbol in them in
the film but at the center of the film
the most fundamental and and most
memorable parts of the film involved
what I'll call sort of the third segment
I don't know that the segment's are
actually equal in in proportion in terms
of time I think the third is the longer
one but the third sequence is the
Odyssey or the quest in which Ricci and
his young son embark on in order to
recover his bicycle so he spends the
whole so I think he gets his job gets
his bike starts his job on Friday has
his bike stolen on Friday or maybe it's
on Saturday but in any case he he then
he then gets his bike stolen he then he
then asks for help from various sources
and the following day he spends the
entire day walking through the city of
Rome looking for the thief trying to
find his bike he actually finds the
thief as you'll see in the grand climax
of the film although the thief turns out
to be as as miserable and and at least
as much without prospects as poor Ricci
himself and something very interesting
happens in that moment in the film
because your sympathies shift in some
way to the to the thief in an odd way
and you watched as his neighborhood
gathers around the thief to protect him
in certain respects so the so the heart
of the film is this search that the
father and the son go on through the
third day of the of the of the plot
looking looking for the bicycle and as
the day wears on the father the father
becomes more and more nervous more and
more uneasy more and more filled with
anxiety the bike seems to him the
solution to all difficulties and
sometimes the son slows him down and
there and there are scenes in which the
father becomes a net annoyed or angry
with the son getting a bit of head of
myself so I I won't repeat this again
but I'll come back to these matters of
the theme of fathers and sons in any
case there's a moment in this Odyssey
where the father and the son are engaged
in this search for the bicycle when it's
just after I think it's exactly at a
moment when there's a gigantic downpour
they're caught in a terrible rainstorm
and I think in fact the rainstorm may
have caused this the boy has to pee very
badly
and so he treated me and he interrupts
the quest to go and pee I mean he has to
be you have to go you have to go but the
father so upset that the boy has slowed
him down then he slaps him and it's a
tip sleight and you get a sense that
it's maybe the first moment that that
this man has ever struck his son and
it's it's a tremendously fraught moment
and and this is how Batson talks about
it and this is why I mentioned this
moment now it's a way of illustrating
this principle of texture or openness to
experience that's part of the Seekers
vision of the world he is a socially
conscious director but he's not a
programmatic aura or a political apprec
director so Barzan focuses on that
moment I've just described you and he
says the boy needs to pee a downpour
interrupts the chase then he says quote
the events are not necessarily signs of
something of a truth of which we are to
be convinced they all carry their own
weight the rain the need to pee the
father's anger right they all carry
their own weight they're complete
uniqueness they all have Beth Ann says
so finally they all have that ambiguity
that characterizes in effect when a film
is able to capture that ambiguity that
characterizes any fact it's a work of
art right it can't be programmatic if it
does that and in fact the moment I'm
describing is is really in some sense a
version of what I've been calling the
neo-realist counterplot what constantly
happens in good neo-realist films and
what happens again and again in the
Bicycle Thief is that the ongoing quest
for the bicycle is [ __ ] or
interrupted by various kinds of accident
disturbance a strange encounter so that
the so that the search for the bicycle
becomes something much larger than that
and every particular moment in the film
has as bizarre says its own uniqueness
its own its you don't feel that anything
is in the film to further the plot or to
illuminate the character or to tell you
something about what political attitudes
you should have although by the time
you're finished with the film you do
very coherent sense of how the society
is breaking down of what of how people
are sustaining themselves of how about
how difficult life is in post-war Italy
you're aware of all of these things and
and and but and aware of them with the
concreteness and a clarity that you
wouldn't have if you read an abstract
essay you've seen them embodied in a
totally believable fiction but what
gives the fiction its authority what
gives it its power is precisely that you
don't feel you're watching a ceremony
you don't feel you're watching something
in which in which some political
moralist is beating you over the head
and telling you oh you better love this
poor guy you but and in fact as the film
goes on one of the things you're
discovers that there are very there are
nasty or bad sides to poor Ricci we
understand that he's driven by economic
anxiety that's very deep in it partly
and certainly mitigates his his behavior
but he behaves crudely and cruelly to
his son never intending to and then of
course their moments when he recovers
and tries to tries to make up with his
son I'll come back to this in a moment
so this passage from bezu also calls
attention then to what I think of as a
signal feature in these films the pet
and especially in the Bicycle Thief that
power that that any moment in the film
has to express a kind of complete
uniqueness the ambiguity that
characterizes reality itself well what
I'd like to briefly do is give you a a
partial account a modest account of De
Sica zone career and then say some
things about the bicycle about Bicycle
Thieves De Sica was a stage actor he
gave regimental performances when he
served in the Army in the First World
War became a stagehand right after the
war and an actor in 1923 he joined a
theatre company in 1925 a touring
company and he became a tremendous
success in a series of performances he
would in 1927 he appeared on stage in
Rome in something called the zabun
reviews and I think it involves singing
and dancing and this was an unbelievable
success and turned him into a kind of
matinee idol or at least the theater
icon
he he made his first film in that same
year in 1922 as an actor and his first
success came he continued to act in
films intermittently for the next decade
but he didn't become a recognizably
serious film actor until his first major
success in 1932 and then he and then for
10 years he's a kind of matinee idol on
in Italian movies he made over 40 films
in the period between it as an actor
between 1932 and 1942 but very handsome
man as some of you may know if you've
seen him and capable of great subtlety
as an actor this may help to explain why
he was such a great director of
non-professional actors because he knew
intuitively I think how to bring out a
performance from it from it from someone
who was not trained in in performing in
acting he begins to direct in 1940 and
makes a series of interesting but
forgettable films I suppose his first
really significant film from one angle
anyway but from if we're especially if
we're interested in the development of
neo realism is a film makes in 1942
co-screenwriter cesare zavattini
entitled the children are watching us
and it's it's a it's I've seen the film
it's it's not a great film but it's an
interesting film and there are some
remarkable moments in it the title tells
you something about the neo-realist
commitment to focus on the
underprivileged and the disempowered in
society the many neo-realist films
focused directly on children and the
children are watching us is one such
film and it almost announces the the
idea that children are among the victims
of society because they are subjected
not only to all the political and social
authorities of the society but also to
the arbitrary authority of their own
parents and their own and their own
immediate family environment so
so the children are watching us
announces this interest in the
disenfranchised and especially in
children and it's a it's a film about
the breakup of a middle-class marriage
mostly told through the eyes of the
children so there are certain things
certain behaviors on the part of the
adults are never fully explained because
you witness and experience the film
through the not just the eyes but
through the perceptions the
understanding the sensibility of
children who are somewhat confused about
what they're seeing the the film that
established him as an international
figure and established neo-realism as an
international movement was one that De
Sica and zavattini collaborated on in
1946 and it was entitled shoeshine and I
sometimes have been tempted to show
shoeshine in this course even though
it's a much less perfect film than
Bicycle Thieves because in its own way
it's so powerful and moving one of the
most interesting things about neo
realism apart from the fact that it was
so short-lived
is how relevant the film still feel
today if you watched shoeshine or
another of the films that I've read I've
listed here Umberto D which is about the
problems of people who have gone into
rid of all of the old people of our
retired pensioners and the problems they
face when there is horrific inflation
the seekin dedicated that film to his
father and it's about an old man who's
very proud he used to be he dresses very
well but he's tremendously isolated he's
terribly poor he's almost reduced to
begging in the course of the film and
there's even a moment near the end of
the film where he contemplates and then
pulls back from suicide so that but but
watching that film today it feels much
less dated than some films that are much
later than that were produced 10 15 20
25 years after it because the theme is
so relevant I mean because we know that
in society today there are so many old
in all Western societies but especially
in the United States there are
pensioners who can't make end
ends meet and the same thing is true I
think in some degree of the roughly of
the fate of children in modern society
so shoeshine although it has a very
melodramatic and violent ending it's a
immensely powerful film essentially it's
a story about two boys two Roman street
urchins who are taken advantage of in
some sense by by by their own relatives
who are trafficking in black-market
goods it's just the same it's said in
the same moment at the end of the war in
fact the film opens with these these
these urchins trying to make a living as
shoeshine boys that's why that where the
title comes from and the shoeshine boys
are wandering the streets of Rome going
up to American soldiers who are
dominating the streets the worst it's
still an occupied City asking soldiers
if they want shoeshines and and the the
the children are unbelievable victims
they're very close friends they end up
buying a racehorse a broken-down old
racehorse that can't race anymore and
they stable at some place and it's a
there they're very excited about about
their about their possession of this
horse and there's some early scenes in
which you see them riding on the horse
with tremendous joy and so forth but of
course this is the dawn before the
miserable night because what then
happens is the kids are taken advantage
of by one of their but by a close
relative they're involved in black
market activities the men the the adults
use the children because they know that
the children are less vulnerable and
they would be if they're caught the
children are --court caught they're sent
to reform school and most of the film
takes place in the reform school you see
these two bright-eyed beautiful young
children no maybe ten years old who are
the fastest and closest of friends when
they go into jail slowly breaking down
you see their humanity being beaten out
of them by the conditions in the reforms
in the in them in the children's prison
it's a it it's a terrible disturbing
film in part because you could you can
you you can see that the people who are
running the prison actually mean well
they're not vicious evil people
want to harm children they just came the
sir the system seems designed simply to
cause more harm than good and and to
destroy the vitality and optimism in kid
and and when I say the film ends
melodramatically one one child strikes
out at his erstwhile best friend and
knocks him down a bank and he dies
there's an effect accidentally murders
is a person who had been his dearest
friend I think it's a failure in the
film I think that you didn't need the
murder for the meanings of the film to
be available I think that the seeker
learned something from that and when you
watch the ending of the Bicycle Thief
one of the things I hope you'll ask
yourself is why is it so apparently
undramatic and why does that undramatic
ending in the end seem so profound so
moving so meaningful it's as if it's as
if the c-code sort of learned his lesson
it's as if he drove his point home too
heavily at the end of shoeshine and he
realized that to have a truly organic
text that did what Beth Ann wants texts
to do reflect the unique the unique and
the duty of every of every experience
the ending of the bicycle of Bicycle
Thieves does that much more effectively
as I hope you'll watch for when you when
you're watching the film so shoeshine
but your son was it what made a
tremendous impact and it won the the
first of four Academy Awards that the
seeker won as Best Director for that
this was for the best foreign film of
the year in 1946 and it put neo-realism
on the map and then two years later
Sabatini and and De Sica followed with
what I suppose we could call their
masterpiece Bicycle Thieves I want to
say and this is not a complete and
remotely complete list of the Seekers
films I've just listed some highlights
here because I want to give you a sense
of his work I've mentioned Umberto D
already the last neo-realist film
according to many people and a very
moving one about about an old pensioner
the film two women start Sophia Loren
one of the one of the great sort of
pulchritudinous Italian movie stars of
the 50s and 60s and it got a lot of
attention and there and there were other
interesting many other
films that he made but one of his great
triumphs was the very last film he made
and that's why I want to mention it
Sabbatini return to do an uncredited Co
screenplay
work to do uncredited screenplay work on
finzi-continis and you can feel that 70
nice hand in many moments in the in the
film it's an adaptation of a novel and
of course as some of you may know it's
really a holocaust film it's about the
build-up to the Holocaust and the fins
and continue' are very wealthy Italian
Jews the story is about a poor a young
Jewish scholar who is because of the
anti-jewish laws that are developing in
fascist Italy is barred from using the
public library and he's a very gifted
young scholar he's in his early 20s
so he gets per me so he finds out that
this very wealthy aristocratic family
also Jewish the finzi-continis have a
magnificent library in the
finzi-continis opened their library to
him since he's barred from going to
public life and of course what happens
is you might you might guess this too
it's a wonderful novel although the film
is even more beautiful I think he falls
in love with the finzi-continis daughter
right so it's a it's a class issue you
know the poor boy rich girl and the film
the film that so the foreground of the
film is this cross class romance but in
the background of the film all the it's
something like cabaret but not as
dramatic not as overt because what's
going on in the background of the film
is the is the growth of fascism and the
film ends with many of the characters
we've gotten to know very well both
young and old all of them Jews but some
very aristocratic and some at the bottom
of the social hierarchy all being herded
together being ready to be shipped off
to the camps you don't actually go the
final scenes of the film have them in
the railroad station being being
prepared for their for their final
journey and the the film has a the film
is also full of comedy just as the some
of the passages that I show you in Clips
this afternoon mix comedy with social
with with socially serious themes this
is even truer of the
I'm the finzi-continis though one of the
reasons I like the film so much is that
it's a return to the energies and the
moral passion that had marked the
Seekers earlier career and I think that
my own feeling is the finzi-continis fnz
continues is one of the great European
films it's it certainly would be on my
list of the best 15 or 20 European films
of the sound era and I I think I think
many of you would find it very
instructive and moving but I think
especially so after you saw some of the
true neo-realist films the early
neo-realist films if one can't really
call the garden of the finzi-continis
neo-realist film although it has many
elements in common with those earlier
texts so De Sica was a remarkable man a
significant actor a great director he
directed over 25 he directed 25 films in
his career won four Oscars for Best
Foreign Film he acted in more than a
hundred and fifty films mostly light
comic social manners kind of roles but
there's one exception I perhaps should
mention playing in a film for his friend
Roberto Rossellini
in 1959 Rossellini's greatest film a
film called general della Rovere De Sica
played the lead he plays the general and
it's it's probably his most memorable
performance and it's very very subtle
and good film about political
ambiguities and conflicts of loyalty
it's a and human frailty human
inadequacy you know in a way that's
characteristic of the best neo-realist
work now those are all films I recommend
and urge you to consider watching in
your in your leisure time let me say a
few words now and about about Bicycle
Thieves and I've already implied or
actually said a part of my what I want
to say so I think I can be briefer than
I had originally planned let's say so
let me remind you again about the
structure I mentioned you that the
structure of the film is elegantly
simple that the amount of time that
passes
very compressed and that's helpful
because you you you you've the the the
time compression makes you aware of the
urgency of the quest that the father and
the son are engaged on when they certain
when when they're searching for the
bicycle so one way and and as the story
unfolds a number of things begin to
happen the quest for the bicycle becomes
a kind of Odyssey in which in which
several things happen one is the film
takes you on an exploration of Rome you
actually it's like one of the great city
films it visits the city it explores the
city you see different different it's
not just that you see police stations
and religious institutions and the
catacombs underneath the city where the
union's meet and where reach he first
goes to get help from his union from
union members who promised him that
they'll find his bike very easily and
they give him a plan he's very excited
then the next morning when they follow
the instructions of the union boss
doesn't help so the unions are breaking
down as well as the church as well as
certain kinds of welfare organizations
from the state and so on so one thing
the film becomes then is a kind of
travelogue a kind of exploration of the
city the city's geography as well as the
city's makeup in some way you go into
different neighborhoods and you hear I
think Italians can pick up different
different neighborhoods speech patterns
in the film at least I've been told this
by Natan by native Italians so it's a
kind of travelogue in one sense it
explores this this play and part of the
exploration of course part part of the
exploration involves certain ancillary
or or or or or other themes that are not
that our that are organically linked to
the to the story of looking at going
through the city looking for the bicycle
and one of these one of these of course
is is what we might call the social
themes of the film because as the the
protagonists make their way through the
city searching for the bicycle one we
what you encounter are little vignettes
that tell you something about the social
hierarchies of the society
about the efficacy or in efficacy of its
institutions right I won't go into great
detail here I wondered I hope you'll
draw your own conclusions and name some
of those names some of the specific
examples that reinforce this general
idea but I do want to mention at least
one moment in this in this in this
Odyssey one of the most dramatic and and
disturbingly comic moments in the film
occurs when Ricci and his son actually
think they've seen the thief they think
they recognize him and they follow him
and they get to a essentially a mission
where relatively well-off self-satisfied
Christians are serving meals to the
indigent and the poor right and Ricci
gets into this institution not but not
because he sort of wants the meal or
because he needs the religious uplift
but because he's chasing his thief right
and he finds once he's in there that he
can't get out it turns out that in this
institution that not only do they do the
the poor have to pay for their meal by
by agreeing to all kinds of religious
behaviors prayers and other kinds of
things but they're also locked into the
building they're not allowed to eat
they're not allowed to leave at least
until they finish eating maybe they're
not allowed to leave until they can be
checked to make sure they're not
stealing the soup bowls but in any case
it's a it's it's a very interesting
moment because you can see that even the
people who intend to do well in the
society often do more harm than good and
and of course the implication is that
the traditional religious institutions
and traditional religious arrangements
are not sufficient to take care of or to
war or or adequately to respect the the
difficulties of the poor and that's just
one such moment them in there there are
a number of there a number of others and
there in fact there is one other moment
I should mention as a kind of contrast
I've said that we see many instances in
which we understand that the larger
institutions of society like the police
or the religious system or the union
system are breaking down are not really
helping people but avoid but I've also
said that there are some other sort of
unofficial and non insta
to tional eyes sources of solidarity
uncomfort that emerge in the course of
the film and i hope you'll watch for
them and think about what their what
what their significance is but there's
one but there but there but there's one
moment in which we might say which
complicates this argument because we can
see the social institution of the
society the social institutions of Zion
not actually functioning effectively but
at least showing some compassion and
it's an astonishingly vivid meaningful
moment in the film another one of these
moments so full of multiplicity that the
meanings are are so deeply embedded in
in what you dramatically see that
sometimes you don't even step back to
generalize on the meaning of what you've
seen and this is a scene very early in
the film where reach he actually goes to
retrieve his bicycle and his wife has
figured out a way basically what she
figures out is will sell they have a
little bit of a they sell her dowry she
has a couple of fancy silk sheets and
they take them to the hock shop and they
and they pawn the sheets in order to get
enough money to get the bicycle out of
hock right means they're gonna be
sleeping on mattresses but so what this
is more important right and so and you
see Ricci and his wife go to the pawn
shop which is clearly it's clearly run
by the state it's not like a private
porn book it's obviously a city
institution of some kind and and they
bring them linen up to the guy and and
he looks at them and he says okay I'll
give you this much money and they need a
little bit more because they need more
to get the bike out of hock so they they
ask him for more money and he looks at
he says ah it's not really worth it okay
and he gives them and it's an act of
generosity on his part because he didn't
have to do it he gives them just enough
money for this stuff so that they can
get his bike out of hock and then
completely silent you see him pick this
material up this this pawned bedding
this pawned linen and he turns around I
think he does it he may give it to
another character I haven't looked at
this scene in a year or two so I don't
remember the exact same I think it's the
same man who does it or he may give it
to someone else
with the material the the three or four
sheets that are involved are taken by
someone he walked to the back of a room
and he begins to climb a ladder and as
he climbs you realized that what he's
climbing up is a
he's he's climbing a ladder which is
leaning against a series of shelves that
seem to go on endlessly they seem to be
in an auditorium the size of the city of
Pittsburgh and they go up endlessly high
and every single shelf every single inch
of space on the shelf is filled with
bedding as if the entire city of Rome
has pawned it's betting as if everybody
in Rome is sleeping on mattresses now
the film never makes a comment about
this no one in the film says anything
about it but it's an unbelievably
resonant and rich moment and it's and
it's also it it it does further the sort
of social themes of the film but it
occurs in a moment in which you also see
the pawnbroker showing a moment of
compassion and generosity and if he did
not show that generosity they wouldn't
have been able to get the bicycle so so
it's a it's a complicated moment it does
mean if all this linen has been pawned
there's some question about whether or
not the city services are doing much
good for anybody the the city's in
obvious trouble if nobody has any bed
linen any longer but the implication is
this is an unbelievably impoverished and
and and damaged environment but it's
done in such a quiet and there's even
some it's done in such a quiet way
there's even something almost comic
about the sense you have of the endless
number of these things even the idea
that you have to distinguish one from
the other seems from our vantage point a
bit silly even though each one has a
ticket on it each one belongs to an
individual family so watch for that
moment it has some of that ambiguity
that we've been that that peasant talks
about so the structure of the film is
organic in the sense that nothing that
happens in the film doesn't seem to
arise naturally out of the needs of the
characters we have to find our new bite
we have to find our bite and in the
course of their travels other things
happen the boy has to pee they get
hungry they have to eat or sometimes it
rains they have to get out of the rain
right and that's part that becomes part
of the ongoing sort of organic
development of the of the story you
never once feel I think in this film
that that any event has been imposed
from the outside every event seems to
arise naturally
out of the circumstances and nature of
the characters and that's why I call it
organic it's a deeply or it's a it's a
deeply or organic way of thinking about
the material but it's organic in another
way too of course because it's deeply
coherent when you finally finish the
film and you step back you say okay yes
the film slowed down here and yes the
film seemed to generate what Thorburn
calls a counter plot here nonetheless
the taken as a whole there's a profound
moral and and thematic coherence in this
organically fluid movie so the structure
of the film is part of its essence and
although I haven't put this on the
outline because we've talked about this
so often already pay attention to the
rent wash type camera behavior I mean
this the the film's visual style is like
Jean Renoir's there's a kind of there's
a kind of elegant restlessness to the
camera and that's that that's that
that's very much a part of what the film
of what the film achieves so I in
talking about the social themes all I
meant to call your attention to was the
extent to which in a variety of ways the
film calls attention to the miserably
endangered circumstances of ordinary
people in this broken-down war-torn
environment and it also looks to those
or seems to find without even looking to
those sort of or dramatize will reveal
those sources of support and sustenance
that get us through bad times and as
you're watching the ending of the film
ask yourself what these things mean I
mean what what it means that the that
whether I won't I won't actually tell
you whether he recovers the bike or not
let you see that for yourselves but ask
yourself whether or not he recovers the
bike would it have made any difference
does it matter what given what the film
is finally saying to us in those final
in those final images well character
this is one of the great films about
character I think and especially about
about the relation between the father
and the son there at the very center of
the film I've already said in a way that
this Odyssey that they go on is a
travelogue it teaches us about the
geography and social circumstances and
social arrangements and class system and
institutional systems of
it does that but it also it's also an
odyssey in which the father and the son
get to know each other in the in a
deeper and in many ways much more
disturbing way than has ever happened to
them before the most poignant and
terrible thing about this film in fact
is that the odyssey i've been describing
through rome with his son by Ricci is
also an initiation story a story about
growing up but what happens to reach his
son in this film doesn't happen to most
young boys until they're much older and
it happens gradually not all at once but
what reaches son discovers in the course
of this day are his father's flaws he
discovers things about his father that
no boy really wants to know even if he's
67 years old like your professor and he
discovers these things about he
discovers these things about his father
in the most stressful circumstances his
father as violent toward his father is
indifferent toward him then there are
moments when after his father feels
terrible anxiety and grief over the way
he's treated where his father tries to
make up with him and these and you can
see the boy not wanting to let him do it
it's unbelievably rich and I don't think
anyone who pays attention to this will
fail to recognize the interactions
between the father and son as
unbelievably true been marvelously
accurate to the way in which loving
parents and loving children often
interact with each other because they
have many moments where they're really
not happy with each other at all what
the boy discovers about his father are
some things that no child ever wants to
know about his father not just that he's
flawed but that he's deeply deeply
flawed that he's that he's capable of
really terrible behavior and the boy is
it and something that happens in this
artist is one of the subtlest things
about the film the basic relations
between fathers and sons are reversed
and we find that the son this little
child is twice in the film in the
condition of in the position of having
to rescue his father I'm simplifying
certain things because I don't want to
give away the plot but you'll see how
this works out in the film I mean there
are two moments in the film in which
Ricci's fate would be far more dire
than it is because of his sons presence
his son in a sense is his savior so that
there but fathers are supposed to
protect their sons not the reverse and
part of the meaning of this adventure is
that Ricci has been reduced to such a
miserable level that he even has to rely
on his sons help in order to get you
know in order to get by this and both of
them father and son experienced this
reversal so it's a it's a
psychologically traumatic and deeply
moving experience although don't
misunderstand I'm not suggesting that
the child doesn't come to terms with
what he does come to terms with what he
learns I think it's quite remarkable I
mean I I mean I would have had trouble
with what that boy comes to terms with
as an adult and he does it as a child
but I think of course it's also
believable as you'll see so the so the
film the film is profound and serious
about the social circumstances of
post-war Italy it's profound and serious
about the indifference of certain kinds
of institutional arrangements to the to
the real miseries of human experience
and it is a powerful and deep
exploration of human character and
especially centrally the relation
between Ricci and his son the relation
between father's and becomes a kind of
one of the great parables of the
relations between adults and children
between father it's one of the great
father and son stories of of all time
let me conclude by saying a couple of
words about the title I mean there's
much more in the film I wish I could
talk about but you by this time in the
course if you can't get this stuff
yourself I haven't done my job I hope
all of you are watching films much more
attentively and carefully than you had
before I hope that your enjoyment has
been increased rather than decreased by
what you've learned in this course and
let the Bicycle Thief be a test because
in many ways it's not the kind of film
most of you guys would go out to watch
first of all it's only it's in black and
white
second it's whatever it is more than
fifty years old but I think you'll I
think you'll recognize that it that it
hasn't aged that that that that the film
is as compelling now as it was when it
was maybe even more compelling now than
when it was made because some of the
political turmoil has disappeared
there's no longer there's no
no longer the the taint of fascism
hanging over Italian artistic
productions as there were at the end of
the war there's a historical sense of
the importance of this movement so maybe
we can look at these at these
neo-realist films with a more objective
eye than than the original audience is
good in any case the title is an
interesting one when it was first
translated into English it was - and in
fact it's still widely known you might
have noticed a few slips of the tongue
on my part where I started to call it
The Bicycle Thief and the reason is it
still often called that and a winner was
originally brought into the United
States and translated both in Great
Britain and in the United States it was
called The Bicycle Thief now the Italian
is in the plural it's laddie de
bicicleta thieves of the bicycle would
be the literal translation right now the
question is why the plural and I think
you can imagine the answer just from
that opening sequence that I showed you
this afternoon can you what Wyatt why
would it be plural why would the title
be plural one of the reasons is from the
very opening sequence we see that
everybody that first of that the bicycle
is a very ambiguous and complicated
symbol in the film
if symbol is a bad word because it's
such an actuality that it seems
pretentious to call it a symbol you see
hundreds of maybe thousands of bicycles
in the film that's part of what makes
reaches loss of the bicycle so poignant
you have the sense as he's walking
around the city that my god everybody
has a bicycle there are 10 million
bicycles in this city poor Ricci can't
find one can't find his it seemed I mean
there's something that there's something
horrific about the idea that's an item
so common could still for Ricci be so
precious as to constitute his livelihood
or a threat a threat against his
livelihood if he can't find the bicycle
and you can guess now on the basis of
what I've already said
one reason for why the title is plural
why as rich he's walking around looking
for his bicycle walking through a city
full of hundreds and thousands of
bicycles what might he think what might
you think if you needed the bicycle
desperately why not pinch one right why
not feet
so one of the reasons that the title is
plural is that reaches one of the
thieves right I mean oh I'm only
suggesting that he's a thief by sort of
psychological inclination he looks
lovingly at by as you'll see the plot
makes this even more explicit I didn't
want I don't want to give him away the
plot he actually I will he actually does
in a certain sense become a thief but
long before he becomes a literal thief
and actually puts his hands on someone
else's bicycle you you and I even think
that some people in the audience may get
the idea before reach he does I mean
you're watching this guy walk so
terrible looking for look looking
everyplace for his bicycle and he's
surrounded by bicycles he's inundated by
bicycles
it's a after he recovers the bicycle
before he goes to work
his wife asks him to take him to a
special location she wants to thank
someone it turns out that that he and so
and they get on the bus she rides behind
him and he rides over on the bike and he
waits outside this place when his wife
goes up his wife is taking a long time
so he leans his bike against the wall
and he starts to go up the stairs and he
looks he sees that his bike is
vulnerable so he walks down he finds the
kidney gives them I think he gives the
kid a coin and tells the kid to guard
the bike and then he starts walking up
the stairs again this is very early in
the film and think how clever this is
and you're aware of how vulnerable the
bike is from that moment Longley this is
a day before it's stolen
right and and you're you're aware of how
precious it is and as he ascends the
stairs you actually become afraid that
his bicycle might be stolen you'll begin
so that one of the reasons that the
title is ambiguous is I think in the end
that the title encompasses not just the
thief who steals reaches bike and not
just Ricci himself who contemplates
becoming a thief in his desperation but
also the audience which becomes
complicit in reaches impulse to
criminality because we ourselves thank
God steal the goddamn bike take the bike
stop worrying about get it get away
there's a bike you can take and I think
anyone watching the film has this
feeling after a relatively short time so
that we're Bicycle Thieves as well so
part of the subtlety of the time and
you'll see as though as the film works
itself out I've already implied this
when they finally catch up with the
alleged with the thief the guy they
think is the thief he
is out to be an even more miserable
specimen than poor Ricci he's an
epileptic he has these out of work he
has to be protected by his community his
mother's very protective of him there's
some modest minor possibility that he's
acting they's faking his his his his
mental problems and maybe faking
everything but I don't think so I mean
and you can judge yourself whether this
is what is in a case the case when is
any case surely true is that is that the
neighborhood coalesces around him
because Ricci and his son are strangers
and are attacking someone from their
neighborhood right and and so so so when
it when this when this happens one of
the things that you what one of the
things you feel is not just that that
the thief that Ricci was going going
after deserves some sympathy to you
begin to feel some sense that his
difficulties are not that you excuse his
fevery but you understand it in a in a
deep and generous way I think and that
complicates your sense of who thieves
are and what thieves are like and then
you've come to recognize that rich is a
potential thief and you care about rich
you see what a loving father he is what
a desperate how desperate he is to take
care of his family so you you you
sympathize with him and then you realize
if you've been thinking about it that of
course you've been coveting bicycles
yourself as if new as so the audience
and the real thief and Ricci the
would-be thief are all implicated
together as if what he's saying is that
our common humanity is what Bicycle
Thieves suggests and that's one of the
reasons that the title needs to be
plural because the film is not about a
single Bicycle Thief it's about the
Bicycle Thief in all of us
enjoy the film
you